hey phil you've agreed graciously to do
some songs for us this morning which i
would like to hear
yeah we got in the air tonight you want
to do that first i could do that first
or we can do the other one first i
wonder which uh which which period this
was for phil in the air tonight
was this the happy album or the sad
album oh this is the this is the very
album this is the very bitter
and when you write a song like this what
is it just come into your head all of a
sudden someone did
it did you mean you're just sitting
around i mean you've written so many
great tunes what are you just sitting
around one day and a song just flies
into your head tell me how that works no
i
i mean actually this song i
i didn't intend to make her album with
this first album face value i just
started to write some songs you know
because as messages to my first work in
fact
really and the first one one of the
first ones i wrote was in the air
tonight
and this is to your first wife well the
album the song is on the on the album
yeah this one i don't know what it's
about because the first one
uh that's in the air tonight was the
lyrics just
came out are you ready for in the air
tonight let's do a little in the air
tonight
right this is brad and daryl on
[Music]
it
well i've been waiting for this moment
for all my life
alone
i can't feel it
[Music]
this is going to take about three weeks
at this temperature
well if you told me you were drowning
i would not lend a hand
i've seen your face before my friend
but i don't know if you know who i am
two
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh lord oh lord
well i've been waiting for this moment
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i've been waiting for this moment for
all
[Music]
[Applause]
listen to that hey that sounded nice